on l'appelait gros cube à l'oeil parce
qu'il était on l'appelait gros cul parce
que on a le même défaut tous les deux
mais Beloeil et et des Mac m'aimaient
beaucoup et puis aussi alors elle me
donnait de l'argent j'étais comme si
j'avais toujours beaucoup d'argent dans
les poches mais c'est du joli navarrow
bonsoir
Roger Hanin
si Roger Hanin Navarro Navajo ça fait 12
ans que ça existe Navarro et ça
rassemble combien 10 millions de
téléspectateurs à chaque fois non 10 12
non quelquefois c'est incroyable vous
êtes vraiment l'acteur français le plus
populaire en plus ça s'exporte dans 40
pays faire qu'à 40 pays dans le monde
qui qui vous voient et vous êtes une
star vous pouvez même plus vous balader
incognito à l'étranger maintenant non
alors celle du succès pourquoi parce que
c'est un flic humaniste comme ça qui
sait où est le bien où est le mal j'ai
du mal à dire parce que tout d'un coup
je vais dire alors je vais vous
expliquer pourquoi ça dit ça devient un
peu risible mais la réflexion je me suis
dit que peut-être ils étaient habitués à
moi ils m'ont connu acteur enfin à 25
ans 30 ans 40 ans 50 60
on peut dire votre âge Roger non ça vous
embête bien sûr 74 ans je voudrais faire
[Applaudissements]
attention
alors
Eugène un énorme succès en tant que en
tant qu'acteur peut-être parce que vous
aviez une revanche à prendre sur la vie
peut-être parce que quand vous avez
commencé votre vie
c'était pas simple vous dites petit j'ai
vécu l'humiliation car j'étais juive
j'étais pauvre et vous dites je revois
encore mon père employé des PTT préparer
ses cours du soir pour gravir les
échelons vous avez souffert de ça et ton
petit vous aviez vraiment je vais vous
dire je vais vous décevoir parce que
c'est vrai tout ce que vous dit est
exact mais j'ai pas souffert de ça alors
me dit mais vous avez insistez pas je
n'ai jamais été malheureux parce que
j'ai toujours vécu dans c'est pas pour
faire joli ou violoncelliser dans un
climat d'amour donc on peut pas on ne
peut pas être malheureux on bagarre dans
une rue on rentre vous avez beaucoup
d'argent quand même parce que quand vous
étiez petit vous jouiez au ballon
attendez c'était le ballon c'était du
papier attaché avec des avec des bouts
de ficelle mais c'était formidable
c'était magnifique
on se bagarrer dans les rues on rentrait
on était ensemble votre mère vous
caresse la nuque tout ça c'est
magnifique vous avez une tente qui était
mendiante Esther était mendiante oui
j'ai filmé à l'époque on était pas très
pas très intelligent parce que
aujourd'hui mendiant bon j'ai pas que ça
fasse chic mais enfin compte tenu bon
des gens qui sont sur le bord du chemin
on accepte mais nous on avait honte
d'avoir une tente mondiale quand je
sortais du cinéma je voyais ma tante qui
m'endit je me sauver j'étais un crétin
je sortais du stage je la voyais
mondiale avec ses filles je la
connaissais pas c'était pas pour pas lui
donner de l'argent quand même pardon
c'était pas pour pas lui donner de
l'argent plus on n'avait pas d'ailleurs
mais c'est parce que j'avais honte mais
j'ai j'avais tort est-ce que vous avez
été plus humilié finalement par
l'antisémitisme qui régnait pendant la
guerre en Algérie parce que les lois
anti Juifs se sont de pétains se sont
appliqués en Algérie vous avez pas plus
été humilié par ça finalement que par la
pauvreté j'étais humilié par ça parce
que j'avais une impression de vivre une
injustice absolue c'est-à-dire il y a eu
le numerus clausus ça veut dire qu'on
renvoyer les élèves juifs et je me dis
j'étais un très bon élève j'étais très
bon sport je faisais rire tous mes
copains on me dit Monsieur part pourquoi
parce que vous êtes juifs mais pourquoi
ça c'était une chose que je ne pouvais
pas comprendre votre père a été viré
aussi des PTT
il a tout il a tout confisqué
il y en aura 14 ans vous allez
travailler comme commis chez borjo vous
aviez le nom de de Alain qui est le nom
de votre mère en fait et il y a un ami
qui vient vous rendre visite et qui vous
appelle par votre vrai nom Lévis et le
chef du personnel vous dit je trouve ça
parfaitement atroce il vous dit ah vous
avez honte de votre nom les vies vous
avez bien raison c'est devenu terrible
pour vous ayez quoi
mais j'ai répondu oui parce que
finalement je finissais par avoir honte
de mon nom vous savez quand j'étais ça
fait chic j'étais jeune officier de
l'armée de l'air à 19 ans j'allais dans
des messes d'officiers et puis bon
sympathisé 19 ans tout le monde était
formé je les connaissais pas et en
sortant vous allez faire des virer et
avec moi et mes commentaires comment tu
t'appelles
et j'avais toujours attendre tard du
lévisé par le dire mais c'est drôle la
mentalité qu'on finissait par avoir et
d'ailleurs la meilleure preuve en est
c'est que quand vous êtes arrivés en
France dans les années 50 vous venez à
Paris pour faire pharmacies vous avez
pas ça pas duré longtemps vous avez
choisi un pseudo c'était pas le Gendron
c'est ça oui vous savez vous savez ce
que vous savez les endroits vous savez
ce qui se passe quand même aujourd'hui
non vous choisissez en 1950 comme nom
Paul Gendron oui et aujourd'hui Gendron
c'est le nom du mari de Marie-Caroline
Le Pen
c'est un sens je ne l'aurais pas fait à
l'époque je rendront c'était le le
qui que ce soit je dirais mais c'était
le c'était le nom de la femme de mon
frère alors jean-roche je trouve que ça
faisait très français
bien et 50 ans plus tard donc vous êtes
très connu comme acteur vous avez
parfaitement réussi et vous écrivez et
je pense que peu de gens enfin peu de
gens il y a un certain qui le savent
enfin c'est moins connu que Navajo vous
êtes déjà écrit 6 bouquins vous écrivez
depuis l'âge de 13 ans et là vous
publiez voilà vous publiez dentelle chez
grassez zoom zoom mon garçon voilà
très bien ça veut dire quoi
ils sont tous fous Roger
au début ça fait un peu peur
ou quand on fait de la promo on le dit
dans les autres émissions on fait
semblant de pas en faire nous on dit
voilà
une multiplicité de personnages qui sont
assez extravagants assez fantasme des
intrigues un peu délirantes et toujours
quand même autour de un propos précis
une idée centrale et l'idée centrale de
celui-ci c'est l'ostracisme c'est le qui
frappe le sexe féminin
Roger Hanin trouve que dans la
littérature dans la vie on parle
beaucoup des pieds des mains des jambes
qu'on parle jamais du sexe
beaucoup de la sexualité de la
sensualité de l'érotisme mais le sexe
féminin anatomique ou physiologique
c'est quelque chose dont on ne veut pas
parler qu'on ne veut pas boire c'est
mystérieux
tout le monde aussi d'ailleurs mais
ça ressemble pas à ça mais c'est vrai
qu'en général c'est vrai des enfants les
terroristes faut pas regarder faut pas
parler on m'a regardé on s'est baissé
même les amants entre eux c'est très
rare par exemple on le sait que masculin
on le voit il est là mais c'est très
rare que l'homme regarde le sexe féminin
faux faux
bien et alors c'est un livre non c'est
un livre qui est révolutionnaire parce
que c'est un des premiers livres qui qui
choisissent ça comme comme sujet comme
il est central enfin il anatomie
sur des chats
il y a une jeune fille qui s'appelle
Aurélie qui a 16 ans qui est dans un
collège catho je le fais à votre place
elle est élevée par un personnage qui en
fait le compagnon de sa mère qu'elle
appelle oncle Louis et elle devine que
sa mère est prostituée tu vois ça
commence fort c'est la gamine à la
saison elle se doute que sa mère est
prostituée ou Sémiramis qui est une
maison de plaisir on dit pas bordel on a
une maison de plaisir je vous le dis
parce que ça vous le saurez maison de
plaisir qui est sur les hauteurs de
Honfleur voilà alors elle couche avec
Louis il a quand même 70 ans le mec
c'est ça hein ça vous dérange pas avec
des gamines de 16 ans couche avec des
mecs de 60 ans est fait dans ce sens
dans l'inverse ça me trouve ça un petit
peu grotesque gênant d'accord
alors voilà donc elle couche avec tonton
Louis et puis oncle Louis et puis après
le retrouve sa mère voilà et là on se
retrouve dans cette maison de plaisir
alors parlez-nous quand même un peu de
je sais pas du personnel d'abord puis
après des clients parce qu'il y a une
faune qui est quand même assez
extraordinaire c'est un donc manoir qui
est tenu par on appelle la châtelaine en
réalité c'est un homme qui s'appelle
Amédée
et qui est un travelo bon arnacher façon
on dit voir rôle réalisé par
confetté par Jérôme Bosch c'est un
complètement fou qu'il peut au milieu de
caniche et qui a il y a curieusement
cette homosexuel a un enfant de 11 ans
dès que vous me lâchez dès que vous me
suivez pas vous faites comme ça parce
que sinon
donc il s'appelle Guillaume petit homme
et donc Aurélie qui va prendre le
pseudonyme de dentelle donc tombe
amoureuse aussi après oncle 70 ans de ce
garçon qui a 12 ans m'aider voilà petit
homme et là elle rencontre alors ses
futurs collègues alors là il y a des
personnages évidemment fantasmes inédits
inattendu bon il y a une faune assez
extraordinaire il y a guichounet qui est
algo il y a pas de non ça va jusque là
ça me dit de ce gros
qui est un nom horrible personnage et
puis il y a mais c'est un arabe qui qui
qui est pas gentil
mais moi j'ai voulu savoir quel était la
jubilation le bonheur d'être raciste de
dire du mal des Arabes du mal des jupes
et j'ai voulu et je me suis aperçu qu'il
y avait une espèce d'excitation
extraordinaire je n'arrêtais plus vous
arrêtez plus de le décrire attention
déjà vous êtes là en fait j'ai arrêté et
puis il y a un incendie il y a une
partie de poker historique il y a un
meurtre
tout ça c'est amusant et surtout il y a
pour ne pas ne faites pas ça il y a
églantine qui est une
une taille de de d'aigle et qui est avec
son porripolite Bulot pour bureau
Corinne kayak et une mouette rouge il y
en a avec des yeux noirs il y a
également Elga qui est une mouette
là on est passé à ça là je pense que je
pense
quand on écrit il faut rien se refuser
il n'y a pas Chappie chapeau non non
Magali douka alors vous vous dites en
fait que les maisons de plaisir comme
vous dites ça a rien de d'inconvenant
pour vous vous dites non c'est un
échange finalement après tout vous dites
très clairement on achète des baba au
rhum contre de l'argent on peut acheter
des oui je sais pas pour qu'on trouve un
convenant de caresser une peau d'une
femme une bouche de mandrez charnue etc
le principe du Sémiramis je me dis pour
ceux qui veulent y aller je n'ai c'est
que l'argent est un sésame entre le
désir et le plaisir on a le désir d'une
femme
[Applaudissements]
j'ai quitté ma maison
j'adore alors quand vous étiez enfant
non c'est pas plastique
bertrandier pour des prostituées et pour
des pour des macs vous rêviez d'être Mac
en fait ce qu'il faut savoir ah oui ça
c'est un scoop énorme c'est que le rêve
c'est vrai c'est vrai vous auriez fait
un super match en plus vous avez la
dégaine
avec vous je vais vous dire d'abord que
j'étais rejeté petit faut que je dis
j'étais d'une beauté stupéfiante on
l'appelait gros cube à l'oeil parce
qu'il était on l'appelait gros cul parce
que on a le même défaut tous les deux
mais Beloeil et des marques m'aimaient
beaucoup et puis aussi alors elle me
donnait de l'argent j'étais concis
j'avais toujours beaucoup d'argent dans
les poches
on se rapproche quand même de Raymond
vétouan c'est vrai c'est tout le monde
était étonné d'avoir plein d'argent j'ai
acheté du chocolat des réglisse à tout
le monde et voilà parce que j'étais
finalement Mac aussi hein donc voilà
mais le problème de Roger c'est que
quand il a compris que les Mac étaient
aussi des indiques il a c'est là où
c'est la grandeur d'âme de Navarro il a
pas voulu être max c'est vrai alors
j'étais plutôt beau garçon star du
basket j'étais un peu un peu paresseux
un peu vaniteux donc plutôt que de
courtiser les gonzesses quand on
courtise on s'abaisse vous l'avez vu
avec 42 janvier
ce soir vous êtes gentil et Stéphane
souvent donc ça change un peu et alors
vous préfériez aller au bordel quoi
plutôt que passer du temps à courtiser
les filles c'est ça ou la baratiner
c'était des magnifiques j'avais un peu
d'argent que j'avais c'était 300 francs
de l'époque j'allais je connaissais tous
les bordel d'Alger le Chabanais la lune
aussi
le Sphinx la lune ceci à Paris
on était gentil avec nous bon on partait
on partait je joue au basket on a
travaillé on avait l'esprit libre on
était apaisé c'est magnifique
[Rires]
par Paula la maltaise oui
c'est une femme de 45 ans d'une femme
qui faisait des cours dans la même
épicerie que ma mère je la voyais le
matin
mais quand on est quand on est à dos on
rêve de rencontrer le grand amour tout
ça c'était pas je sais pas ça manquait
pas de romantisme ça non oui ça manquait
de romantisme c'est vrai mais je pensais
pas au romantisme à l'époque je possède
je pense à ne pas m'ennuyer à ne pas me
répéter vous avez raison alors ceci
étant ça dû faire quand même un super
bon apprentissage parce que après quand
vous avez rencontré je dirais des des
femmes rangées vous deviez être un super
en amont parce que vous aviez été
réclamations
et vous trouvez pas les femmes après
vous avez pas trouvé les femmes rangées
un peu banales par rapport à ce que vous
aviez connu avec des filles du Chabanais
par exemple parce que non parce que je
les ai connu très tard
j'avais 19 ans avant ça
j'étais naïf et je connaissais pas
c'était naïve de 12 ans un homme qui se
prostitue ça vous gêne
ça me fait de la peine mais ça me gêne
pas parce que si je prostitue c'est que
il a souvent de raison forte ça vous
gêne plus qu'une femme de voir un homme
se prostituer oui parce que je suis
allons-y je suis un vrai macho quoi
[Musique]
bien très bien ça veut dire quoi quand
on applaudit non c'est quand je mets des
amis c'est normal je vous attendez mais
alors si vous voulez je vous ai cueilli
là je vous attendez j'attendais que vous
arriviez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bien alors maintenant on va faire une
nulle
on bouge pas
[Musique]
bon vous vous arbitrez Stéphane d'accord
la mauvaise idée
maintenant vous m'avez collé ça dans le
cigare vous allez vous appeler
jean-guyez Stéphane pour toute la vie ça
marche
je suis dans la mer et je vous emmerde
bien alors Roger vous êtes prêt
interview nul est-ce que vous préfériez
votre père ou votre mère ma mère ah
ouais vous dites carrément j'adorais mon
père mais moi je préférais ma mère c'est
bien un petit d'Alger j'aime bien ça
dans le sud c'est un peu comme ça non
oui
vous préfériez Staline ou Hitler saline
Staline pourquoi parce qu'il a tué plus
de gens
j'avoue que je ne crois pas qu'il est
tué plus de gens là je vais faire dans
ton sens de l'humour
Staline
c'est l'homme qui a dévoyé l'un des plus
beaux idéal que l'idéal communiste mais
maintenant je sais que c'est la mode de
comparer des communistes et des nazis et
moi c'est pas mon sentiment d'accord oui
c'est vrai qu'on compare on dit il y a
eu deux totalitarismes au 20e siècle il
y a eu l'itlerisme et le stalinisme et
c'est vrai qu'on a on les compare vous
pensez que c'est pas comparable non non
parce que je me suis fait accrocher une
fois dans une émission on m'a dit
comment vais vous dire que vous êtes
communiste tu dis d'abord ne me parlez
pas sur cela
je dis mais moi je vais vous dire
pourquoi parce que je peux vous résumer
l'idéal communiste l'idéal communiste
c'est justice et partage maintenant vous
définissez moi l'idéal nazi
définitivement l'idéal nazi et voyons ce
qui ça se confond c'est vrai qu'au début
l'idée communiste était une plus belle
idée que l'idée nationale socialiste ah
oui je trouve forcément alors est-ce que
vous préféreriez faire l'amour avec une
fille très laide ou un mec très beau il
filtrait laide
quand même c'est vraiment match est-ce
que vous avez plus de circonstances vous
donnez plus de circonstances atténuantes
à des vieux qui se tapent des jeunes ou
à des jeunes qui tapent sur des vieux
plutôt des jeunes qui se tapent des
vieux parce que je trouve c'est aussi de
générosité extraordinaire non j'avais
dit des jeunes qui tapent sur des vieux
[Rires]
j'ai compris que dans votre bouquin dans
le bouquin de Roger dentelle
effectivement Aurélie elle veut se taper
le titre de 70 ans
parce que son bon ils ont fini leur vie
ils ont des tarés quoi
vous êtes un spécialiste
le mot le plus con en amour c'est merci
encore oui oui
le plus con le plus con c'est c'est oui
oui
vous avez compris
alors la bombe atomique arrive dans 5
minutes vous faites quoi
ben je je prie
5 minutes qu'est-ce que je peux faire de
toute façon tu as pas le temps d'y aller
là c'est Miramis c'est en fleur en même
temps
[Musique]
votre partenaire n'est pas très excité
vous lui demandez comment il s'appelle
vous lui faites un truc spécial où vous
cassez en claquant la porte
je crois que je pars sans claquer la
porte
bien élevé non parce que d'abord ça ne
change rien et on se diminue on est en
violant vous croyez pas dit ça il y a 20
ans il y a 20 ans
bien si vous étiez mort vous voudriez
être incarné en quoi attention
on Édouard Balladur
en Giscard d'Estaing ou en pierre
Messmer au pire Messmer en pierre
Messmer
politique mais c'est un héros il a une
belle gueule il est il a parlé net et
puis il avait pendant la guerre il a été
très bien conduit
c'est une très bonne très bonne
interview
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu